In 1963, Jack Welch had been working for three years as a chemical engineer for GE Plastics.
One day while sitting in his office, he heard an explosion from the chemical plant.
Jack's heart sank.
Instead of through the roof profits,...
...his team was responsible for literally blowing the roof off a lab.
As the manager, Jack had to drive out and explain what had happened.
By the end of the 100-mile trip, he was a nervous wreck.
But Charlie Reed, the corporate group executive, didn't fire Jack.
He was more interested in learning from the experience than laying blame.
Jack learned a valuable lesson that day.
When people make mistakes, the last thing they need is discipline.
What they need is encouragement.
Charlie Reed was responsible for keeping Jack Welch in the company...
...where he would later become CEO.
The influence of Charlie Reed as well as that of countless others,...
...changed not only the destiny of Jack Welch...
...but through him, the destiny of GE.
Welcome to the relationship revolution.